Chris Sims his job is to analyze the
draft and he is brutally honest he
surprised me when I heard him on Doug
Gottlieb show where he was talking about
to a tongue of AI Lola and Joe burrow
and I went Sims is doing it again pro
pro football talk live co-host and
hosted the Chris Sims unbuttoned podcast
good morning Chris
hey what's up Danny Boy how you doing
man this year you're doing all right I'm
doing okay let me start with Jordan love
going to the Packers he didn't fall into
their lap they went up to get him and
why why did they move up to get him well
you know I'd like to know the same
answer to that question I I'm not sure I
understand that either you know one you
know okay two things jump out to me the
first thing being who are they scared of
that they thought might trade into the
first round there was no picks there on
the board that were ahead of them at
that moment that we're going to take a
quarterback now I don't know if they
felt like the cold sore I don't know
maybe the Patriots or somebody else I
don't know thought maybe they betrayed
back in the first round to get a
quarterback certainly a possibility but
I have no knowledge of that so that's
curious to me right off the bat and then
- yeah Dan I don't like it
you know you know again Aaron Rodgers
and especially in an era right now where
we're seeing quarterbacks could play 240
years old and he'll play at a really
high level Rodgers is still one of the
five best quarterbacks in the sport so
to me when I look at that I just go well
okay yeah I really like Jordan love he's
a project so he certainly needs to sit
for a year maybe two he's really raw
it's got great high-end talent but I
just wonder if Green Bay will ever
really bear the fruits of anything they
get out of the player because I think by
the time his second contracts coming
around Aaron Rodgers still gonna be
playing quarterback for the Green Bay
Packers so I don't understand that and
you know I would like to see them Dan go
deep into tackle or something like that
you know they still haven't stopped the
49ers run run running I mean most are
still running for the NFC changing I
think Tennessee at 30 or 29 might have
been that team if you're just looking at
you naked they could afford to develop
him in Tennessee that was the thought I
had you go for me
32:26 you got Tannehill there he's a
band-aid for a couple of years and then
maybe you you know you get Jordan Love
and you find your quarterback of the
future that was the thought that I had
you know when they made that move up and
the other part of this Aaron Rodgers
makes a whole lot of money the next two
years then after that that third year is
not devastating against the cap does
Aaron Rodgers end his career in Green
Bay well I think it's dicey right now
you know I think you know Aaron Rodgers
as we know first off you know he can be
a little chippy right I mean he can hold
a grudge we know that yeah I think this
is gonna piss him off I do you know I
wouldn't you know I wouldn't be
surprised if he tried to stick it to
Green Bay two years from now and you
know oh hey yeah I threw for 38
touchdowns and five touchdowns or five
interceptions go ahead have Jordan love
I'll move on see you later
you know and I mean you're right they're
paying them a lot of money but it's not
a lot of money to come you know to where
we're going at the quarterback position
I mean crap you know Jared God's making
as much money as Aaron Rodgers and
they're not even the same stratosphere
so Patrick mahomes is going to be
signing something for 40 million dollars
a year here soon
dad Prescott is going to be making more
money than Aaron Rodgers per year so
yeah it's just a head scratcher to me I
just think it's you know again I
understand accumulating quarterback
talent and at that position there's
great value to it I just don't know if I
see the value to me it's different than
you know we Brett Favre was threatening
to retire you know Tom Brady
there was a slippage in play when they
drafted Jimmy Garoppolo in the second
round and I think the Patriots were
truly concerned and then Patriot then of
course Tom Brady he fixed a few things
about his game and became better and was
you know amazing for another four or
five years stretch you know this to me
smells a lot like John Elway
and Maddox who they drafted out of UCLA
back in the early nineties where you
know I don't know if this team's gonna
get anything out of this pick and some
other teams might bear the fruits of his
talent at some point yeah but Chris I
don't know if the Packers you know the
personality of Aaron Rodgers you're
aware of what this is going to do to him
could this be on purpose that maybe
you're you're gonna you're gonna piss
him off like you want him that way you
know how great
is I mean Dan I think I thought of the
same things and I think it's a great
point you're right maybe maybe this puts
the pressure on them you think to raise
his level of play I don't know I mean
yeah maybe it's some master plan to -
maybe what you're saying - where they're
going okay maybe we just don't want to
pay that type of money two or three
years from now on our roster they're
willing to move on from a guy like Aaron
Rodgers I would doubt that but you know
who knows maybe we're starting into a
new age in football where teams are
gonna start looking to to make that
switch to go with the young quarterback
not have that big number on the salary
cap because we've seen Seattle won a
Super Bowl that way Kansas that he won a
Super Bowl that way the Eagles have won
a Super Bowl that way maybe that'll be a
new trend I don't know it's really
interesting and I think you bring up
some good questions for sure he's Chris
Simms NBC sports analyst former NFL
quarterback Dolphins have a good day
yesterday yes they did you know Miami
you said it dad I mean yes I'm not the
huge huge fan of Atilla I certainly
thought he was a first-round Talent I
did the injury history the style of play
the size of the human being would
concern me
you know I think for some reason people
think this is like Lamar Jackson and
Kyle Emery and he did be able to run
around the field and play the way they
play and I would first off just argue
and go no Lamar Jackson and Carla Marie
are the fastest people on their team
like they beat the receivers and the DBS
and races that's how fast they are and
even they have a hard time scrambling so
yeah with the injury history it
certainly concerns named N and when I
really evaluated him there was so many
other plays where I came away gun ooh
did he hurt his knee
ooh did he hurt his shoulder Oh getting
hurt his ankle and that concerned me as
well let alone you know I said I don't
want to bag on the pyre I just think
he's being overrated in the evaluation
process a little bit I think he's
getting a lot of credit for the Alabama
machine and which it is and we're in
this era of we get the quarterback all
the credit when things like that happen
and I think he's benefiting a little bit
from that you know a little overhyped in
my opinion from that standpoint what
about the
chargers I mean I love Justin herbart I
do so I understand them picking him at
number six to him sitting there on the
board you know I could sit here and
argue that I think he might have the
highest ceiling at any of the
quarterbacks to the track hmm now the
people talk about you know issues listen
decision-making yeah maybe not always
perfect I get that but at the same time
I would say a lot of the issues I had
with with Justin Herbert I came away gun
well it's a crappy offense but you know
there's not a lot of talent around him
you know the offense was choppy at times
I didn't blame Justin Herbert listen if
you put Justin urban on LSU or Alabama
he was gonna his stats and play was
gonna look a whole lot different I can
promise you that so I think he's a
big-time talent and then the Chargers
getting kenneth murray dan later on in
the first round and you know the 20s
there man this Chargers defense they
already a borderline Super Bowl type
defense and now you've had this type of
linebacker that second level with
Derwent James a strong safety and all
the other talented guys they got I go
Wow watch out for the Chargers yeah I
felt the same way because we look at the
Chargers and say boy that's that's quite
an offense there and I always remind
people the reason why I thought that
they could have won the Super Bowl a
couple years ago was because they had a
defense that went along with that great
offense and now you look at this
situation with that defense is elite at
least elite it looks like it can be
elite no I mean I'm with you dad I think
you're siding you're spot on
I mean hey I don't think a lot of people
realize even last year with the puller
record the Chargers were one of the five
best defenses in football and you know
they got Lindell joseph and free agency
we know the pass rushers they have they
have Jerry Tillery who was a first-round
pick last year from Notre Dame who is
gonna I think you know be a force to be
reckoned with here in year two and then
yeah you mentioned the Derwent James
Chris Harris jr. in free agency Casey
Hayward's already there I mean they just
they got a very talented football team
and like you said the offense is it a
pretty good spot they got to sure up
that old line a little bit here and
grouts two and three but I'm with you
the Chargers are one I'm putting a
little mark next to to say watch out for
in 2020
Tom Brady do yesterday oh you know well
first off I mean he's still got to be
flying high about being down in Tampa
getting drunk this week I mean that was
awesome
Kristen worse I really applaud the moves
of the Buccaneers to try to get somebody
to play right tackle Tristan worse
didn't play right tackle at Iowa I'll
say oh well I have some questions yes I
have some question you know in my
evaluation I thought Tristan worse was
more of a guard than a tackle and they
really need the tackle now if he has to
move to guard that won't be the worst
thing in the world but man that's a big
guard though Chris that it's a big guard
I know I get it I I got you but you know
the foot speed of the athlete does not
match the numbers at the combine would
you watch film and you if anybody wanted
to go back there watch the Penn State
game watch the Michigan game and there's
a few other games that are very
concerning with people just beating him
because of lack of foot speed so you
know I'm sure the Bucks did their due
diligence there and feel like they can
work on it work with him in those areas
and I think nonetheless it's a great
thought and they needed to protect Tom
Brady if they want to play the style of
football they want to play down to Tampa
best quarterback available tonight best
quarterback available I think for me is
the kid Lewton from Oregon State okay
mmm yeah you know me on Island always
the same as everybody else you know but
I look at him as good size you know good
arm really consistent accurate decision
maker can throw with a little power and
anticipation I think he's the next guy
up for me that I look at to go you know
I would take a chance on him it's either
him or Nick Eason from Washington it's
one of those two Easton's a little raw
Dan but does have a big-time arm and I
think teams that value that are going to
look at him and he makes a lot of
awesome throws you know there's some
there's some off-the-field issues with
him I think people not so sure how
detailed and willing he is to work at
the position and things like that but he
does
a big talent who made the move yesterday
where you went they have no idea what
they're doing
oh gosh man
III don't I I guess the one just makes
me scratch my head the most what prize
either the Raiders pick with with the
kid Damon Arnett right Ohio State yes
you know I really I like the player I
think he was you know top half of the
second round middle the second round
type of guy but he's a true nickel
corner to my opinion and you know I I
don't like drafting corners that run
four or five seven at the top 20 pick to
the drop you know I don't like drafting
nose tackles or 260 pounds either you
know to me that's that's just a no-no so
there's things about his game I really
like definitely I really like everything
mike Mayock has done to build the
Oakland Raiders except for his first
pick in the first round the last few
year and I'm Leland Farrell and you're
just going with it exactly I mean they
could have got cleland Farrell at 34 or
44 last year in the draft and they took
him off the field and past resting
situations last year you know so to me a
little bit of the draft and the beauty
of it always is and you know this is the
understanding of where players are going
to be picked and the value of picking a
player at that spot you know I think
they probably could have got this kid at
the top of the second round if they
really want to do it had no issues would
be worried about that but either way
they fell in love with him
I just was I was a little shocked by
that in the Eagles with Jalen Rieger at
Tech 21 I have you today Jesse Palmer
today Mark Sanchez out of those three
quarterbacks at their Peaks who had the
best arm Wow damn well I'd like to say I
had the best arm I would like to say
that now I'm sure they're gonna argue
that that's fine
they're definitely more handsome than me
I know that for sure damn that's a
good-looking group you're talking about
there you know and me and you know I've
been around Palmer and Sanchez a little
Palmer a few times bombers they're both
great guys at the Palmer funny story Dan
you know he's the bachelor right yeah
they asked me to be the bachelor
that same year when I was still the
backup quarterback at campus a and I was
like are you kidding me I was like Jon
Gruden will just absolutely eviscerate
me and might cut me if I end up
committing to the bachelors and you know
I I heard that we had a choice before
Palmer I don't know but I know they
asked me I don't know if they were just
waiting for one of us to answer say yes
but that year they asked me as well and
I know I said no pretty quickly and I
don't know if they already had asked
Jesse or waiting for answer I don't know
but I don't I was I was in the shuffle
okay but Jesse does it he's got Tom
Coughlin's as his coach you just had
Gruden as your coat if you played for a
different team you know the interesting
part is they asked Chris and he thought
about being a bachelor and he was
married at the time that's what I
thought was really strange with that
Chris you played on another team would
you know I would never have done it
never your dead dad would have your dad
would have crushed you right I mean I
grew up yes with Sol Simms to be coached
under Bill Parcells all right you think
that would have gone down it you know
I'd also say with Jesse Palmer you know
I don't know how long his career ended
up being but I would question that it
might have been shorter than he woulda
liked because of that but it worked out
nonetheless he's still kicking butt oh
let's put it this way he had a longer
career off the field that's right he
definitely did and he's kicking butt off
the field so he should be a shame for
any decision C bit yeah he did well hey
great to talk to you again good stuff
and we appreciate your time as always
Chris anytime man be good be safe I'll
talk to you soon but for is Simms NBC
sports football analyst